the u.s envoy to iran says the blockade  of qatar has gone on for too long  brian hook says the gulf dispute is  damaging stability  prosperity and security as well as  harming shared regional interests  saudi arabia the united arab emirates  bahrain and egypt cut ties with qatar  more than three years ago  qatar denies their allegations of  supporting armed groups and refuses to  accept any settlement  that compromises its sovereignty  president trump and secretary pompeo  continue  to stress the importance of unity among  the gcc members the dispute has  continued for too long  and it ultimately harms our shared  regional interests  instability prosperity and security  the united states will continue to  stress the benefits  of cooperation with all gcc members  and support steps to rebuild trust  and unity